black clansmen was directed by Spike Lee
and stars John David Washington as Ron
Stallworth and this is the outrageous
true story about a police officer from
Colorado played by John David Washington
who decides to infiltrate the KKK and he
does so by talking to them on the phone
but one of his fellow officers portrayed
by Adam driver goes to them in person
and acts as his surrogate while Ron
talks to them on the phone and gets
inside their heads and so they're
working undercover to try to figure out
what they can learn about the KKK in the
1970s and this is a completely insane
based on a true story movie and I think
Spike Lee's best film since Inside Man I
really enjoyed this movie from beginning
to end I thought it was riveting but
most surprisingly very funny I really
didn't expect that going in because I
tried to stay away from the trailers
I've been trying to do that lately where
I I don't see too many of the trailers
or or know much about the film going in
and I found that I enjoy films or at
least am surprised by films a lot more
in doing that so I was really taken
aback by how hilarious this film
actually is and how often I was laughing
a lot of it is due to the interplay
between John David Washington and Adam
driver then going back and forth trying
to figure out how they're going to play
each other one of them's on the phone
the others in person this is just such a
great idea and it's actually surprising
the film hasn't been made up until now
because not only is it a very relevant
movie for today's times it's just such a
great story and for this film Spike Lee
has taken a considerably more mainstream
approach and I think that was a very
wise decision because this film needs to
be seen by as many people as possible
and to do so you kind of have to adopt
more of a crowd-pleasing element to your
film even though the story is very dark
and in so doing I feel like a lot more
people are going to see this movie and a
lot more people are going to hear the
message and understand its importance
there are some historical inaccuracies
throughout the film and some things have
been more embellished to create more of
a theatrical experience and I'm assuming
that more than likely some people will
find fault with that and thus say this
is a bad film or be angry about that but
I've never really seen a based on a true
story movie that doesn't in some way
embellish things or try to make things
more entertaining for an audience and
that's what this film does a few times
and it didn't bother me I I never
thought that it encroached upon his
message I never thought that it took
away from the film I was constantly
invested and I had a great time watching
it
John David Washington I want to see more
with him there are many times throughout
his performance especially when he
raises his voice where I was like wow
you sound just like your father right
now and it actually gave me goosebumps a
little bit but he really did step out of
what a lot of people might consider a
shadow by being the son of Denzel
Washington here he owned this role he
gave so much to it he was impeccable his
screen presence he was on fire this is a
fantastic performance an atom driver as
usual was magnificent all of the acting
in the film especially for some of the
KKK who I imagine were having a very
difficult time saying and doing some of
the things on screen they really
committed to that role and despite how
funny this movie actually is it somehow
is able to balance the darkness with
that light so beautifully because there
are scenes where I was almost in tears
laughing and then in the next I'm
wincing there's a scene where one person
tells a story about a horrific Allah
violent act and it made me sick to my
stomach and like that's the power this
film has the end credits in particular I
was almost in tears and and so there's a
lot to like about this film really the
only real issue I can find with it that
that bugged me throughout is that it is
a little too long perhaps it's just
there's a few scenes where the pacing
isn't as good as it could be but Spike
Lee has balanced those tones of humor
and darkness so beautifully and I think
that's one of the most important things
you can look at when you watch a film is
how the director has balanced the tone
and it's just about perfect black
clansmen is easily Spike Lee's best film
in years and I'm gonna give it an a guys
thank you so much as always for watching
but I also want to give a special thank
you to a very special young man that I
got to meet recently his name is Sammy
this remarkable young man has dealt with
a lot in his life and I had the pleasure
of meeting him and I just want to say to
you Sammy thank you so much for
watching and how much you inspired me
and how much you can inspire others by
continuing to push forward throughout
the difficulties that you deal with and
I just want to say that your optimism
was very infectious and it was lovely to
meet you Sammy
so thank you guys so much as always for
watching look forward to more reviews
very soon and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]